demain 10 décembre 1963 111 pays membres
de l'organisation des nations unies
célébreront le 15e anniversaire de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
par cette déclaration il est entre
autres reconnu que la volonté du peuple
est le fondement de l'autorité des
pouvoirs publics que nul ne sera tenu en
esclavage que nul ne sera soumise à la
torture que l'arrestation arbitraire la
détention ou l'exil sont des violations
des droits de l'homme que quiconque peut
quitter tout pays y compris le sien et y
revenir
circuler librement et choisir sa
résidence que le mariage ne peut être
conclu qu'avec le libre et plein
consentement des futurs époux que toute
personne a droit à la propriété que
toute personne a droit à la liberté de
réunion et d'association pacifiques à la
liberté de religion à la liberté
d'opinion et d'expression que toute
personne a droit à la recherche des
informations et des idées à participer
librement à la vie culturelle que tout
enfant a droit à l'enseignement que
toute personne a droit au travail que
tous ont droit à un salaire égal pour un
travail égal que toute personne a le
droit de fonder des syndicats et de
s'affilier que toute personne enfin à
droite au repos à des loisirs en janvier
1947 la commission des droits de l'homme
créé par le conseil économique et social
de l'organisation des nations unies
comment ces travaux sous la présidence
de madame et d'arnaud roosevelt le
professeur cassin il représente
activement la france la commission
rédige une déclaration universelle qui
est soumise à l'assemblée générale
siégeant à paris au palais de chaillot
elle est adoptée par 48 voix sans
opposition et 8 abstentions
le 10 décembre 1948 l'homme n'a pas
attendu 1948 pour définir ses droits
mais c'est la première fois après six
siècles d'efforts caractère universel
est accordée à ces besoins de liberté
d'égalité de justice
c'est la première fois que les nations
envisage de faire suivre une déclaration
des droits de l'homme d'un pacte qui les
obligerait à les respecter dans la
révolte de spartacus
il y avait déjà le ferment d'une
déclaration des droits la grande charte
que jean sans terre dû accorder en 1215
à 2000 bars onze anglais était déjà une
déclaration des droits de certains
droits
la pétition des droits que charles 1er
stuart se voir imposer par le parlement
en 1628 comme la déclaration des droits
de 1688 que le parlement impose
après le départ de jacques 2 et qui
résume les droits accordés aux anglais
depuis la grande charte sont des efforts
confus mais fondamentaux le premier
document qui mentionne la liberté et les
droits de l'homme et la déclaration
d'indépendance américaine adoptée le 4
juillet 1776 par le congrès continental
réuni à philadelphie cette déclaration
est précédé d'un très beau préambule
tous les hommes sont égaux ils sont
dotés par leur créateur de certains
droits inaliénables et parmi ceux-ci la
vie la liberté et la poursuite du
bonheur
mais c'est une déclaration limité à la
justification de l'indépendance
vis-à-vis de la couronne britannique
c'est la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen patronnée par la
fayette et sieyès adoptée par la
constituante est placé en tête de la
constitution de 1791 qui se rapproche le
plus de l'universalité parce qu'elle ne
mentionne aucune nation aucun régime
aucune époque elle est certes l'oeuvre
d'une classe mais elle est si vaste
aucune limite social ne peut lui être
imposée elle est la conclusion d'une
évolution qui passe par le cartésianisme
des philosophes et physiocrates les
humanistes les encyclopédistes
c'est pour cela qu'elle est
l'inspiratrice de la nouvelle
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme
jean louis barrault considérant que la
reconnaissance de la dignité inhérente à
tous les membres de la famille humaine
et de leurs droits égaux et inaliénables
constitue le fondement de la liberté de
la justice et de la paix dans le monde
considérant que la méconnaissance et le
mépris des droits de l'homme ont conduit
à des actes de barbarie qui révolte la
conscience de l'humanité et que
l'avènement d'un monde où les êtres
humains seront libres de parler de
croire libéré de la terreur et de la
misère a été proclamée comme la plus
haute aspiration de l'homme
considérant que dans la charte les
peuples des nations unies ont proclamé à
nouveau leur foi dans les droits
fondamentaux de l'homme dans la dignité
et la valeur de la personne humaine dans
l'égalité des droits des hommes et des
femmes et qui se sont déclarés résolu à
favoriser le progrès social
instaurer de meilleures conditions de
vie dans une liberté plus grande
considérant que les états membres se
sont engagés à assurer en coopération
avec l'organisation des nations unies le
respect universel et effectif des droits
de l'homme et des libertés fondamentales
l'assemblée générale proclame la
présente déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme comme l'idéal commun à
atteindre par tous les peuples et toutes
les nations
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme comprend trente articles classés
en deux grandes catégories les droits de
la personne droit civil et droit
politique et les droits économiques
sociaux et culturels quantité de
décision de l'organisation des nations
unies se sont inspirés depuis 1948 de
certains aspects de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme la
convention sur les droits de la femme et
de l'enfant
sur la discrimination raciale sur les
réfugiés sur les apatrides sur l'
esclavage sur le travail forcé
en ce 15e anniversaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
nous devrions avec quelques fierté
prendre conscience et surtout renoncer
un instant à nos facultés critique qui
obscurcissent notre objectivité
cette devise ces trois mots c'est nous
qui depuis plus de 150 ans nous avons
fait fleurir de par le monde
le français individualiste et égoïste
ira au fond d'un continent soigner un
enfant
pourvu qu'on l'y oblige pas sa
fraternité et spontanée généreuse sans
principes à l'égalité le français
accordera un sourire doute 2 et ironique
mais fera une révolution pour que ses
enfants soient égaux et libres à la
liberté essentielle fondamentale
inaliénable ne s'ajoute t'il pas un
devoir le devoir d'être un homme d'être
un homme dans un monde où la dignité
avait besoin de la déclaration
universelle pour nous rappeler qu'elle
n'avait pas complètement disparu
bonsoir
[Musique]